Der gigantische Algen-Gürtel reicht von Mexiko
bis nach Westafrika und bildet eine einzige
Todeszone.
Die Rede ist von der Braunalge “Sargassum”,
die sich in den letzten Jahren in rasanter
Geschwindigkeit ausbreitet.
Und unter der riesigen Algen-Menge leidet
nicht nur der Tourismus, sondern auch ganze
Ökosysteme.
Tiere können sich nicht mehr bewegen oder
Eier ablegen und der Seetang schränkt sie
sogar in ihrer Atmung ein.
Forschungsteams befürchten, dass dies auf
eine Veränderung der Ozean-Chemie zurückzuführen
sein muss.
Die langfristigen Folgen sind noch nicht absehbar,
doch Satellitenaufnahmen der NASA zeigen jetzt
das ganze - wirklich verheerende - Ausmaß.
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Heute aus Kopenhagen an der Ostsee.
Hier hinter mir in der Ostsee da schwimmt
die typische Braunalge.
Sie wird auch Seetang genannt und enthält
Luftblasen, damit sie auch oben auf dem Wasser
schwimmt.
Am Strand findet man sie oft.
Aber es ist hier an der Ostsee noch lange
keine braune Flut.
Unter Experten und Expertinnen wird das Phänomen
die Braunalgeninvasion zwischen Mexiko und
Westafrika nämlich auch als “Brown Tide”,
also “Braune Flut”, bezeichnet.
Beobachtet werden kann das, wenn Braunalgen
an die Küste driften und sich dort in der
Brandung und am Strand verfilzen.
Das ist derzeit der Fall - und zwar unter
anderem an westafrikanischen und karibischen
Küsten.
Das Paradies in diesen Regionen wird zu einer
Todeszone.
Die Braunalgen bilden einen Teppich des Todes,
der alles Leben darin und darunter zerstört.
Es entsteht eine meterhohe Masse, die extrem
nach faulen Eiern stinkt.
Nicht nur Fische, sondern auch viele andere
Lebewesen ersticken in dieser Algenmasse oder
verstricken sich darin.
Darunter auch Delfine, Schildkröten und Vögel,
die sich nicht mehr aus dem Algenteppich befreien
können und sterben.
Im Jahr 2011 wurde dieses todbringende Phänomen
zum ersten Mal an westafrikanischen und karibischen
Küsten beobachtet.
Seitdem gibt es sogar ein Frühwarnsystem
für die Sargassum-Blüten: das sogenannte
“Watch System” (SaWS).
Und jetzt hat sich ein US-Forschungsteam hat
sich extreme Wachstum der Braunalge in den
vergangenen Jahren erstmalig genauer angeschaut.
Dazu wurden Daten aus den Jahren 2000 bis
2018 analysiert, die ein NASA-Satellit aufgenommen
hatte.
Das ist möglich, weil die besagten Braunalgen
neben dem Photosynthesepigment Chlorophill
auch noch den Farbstoff namens Fucoxanthin
aufweisen.
So zeichnen sie sich durch ein charakteristisches
Farbspektrum aus, das sie von allen anderen
Algen gut unterscheidet und eben auch aus
dem Weltall zu erkennen ist.
Das Ergebnis der Fachleute ist nicht nur eindeutig,
sondern auch besorgniserregend: Seit 2011
haben sich die frei schwimmenden Sargassum-Algen
explosionsartig vermehrt. 2011 waren sie vor
allem östlich von Florida - in der sogenannten
Sargassosee - und rund um den Golf von Mexiko
zu finden.
Dann begann allerdings die Ausbreitung der
Algen in andere Regionen, unter anderem in
den zentralen Atlantik. 2018 reichte der Algen-Gürtel
dann vom Golf von Mexiko bis zur westafrikanischen
Küste.
Mehr als 20 Millionen Tonnen der Braunalge
schwammen Schätzungen zufolge im vergangenen
Jahr auf der Ozeanoberfläche.
Im Atlantik erstreckt sich das Band an Braunalgen
über unglaubliche 8.850 Kilometer.
Die dichtesten Konzentrationen konnten in
der Karibik und vor der nördlichen Küste
Südamerikas identifiziert werden.
Laut der aktuellen Studie ein relativ neues
Problem.
Denn vor der Jahrtausendwende an bis zum Jahr
2010 gab es keine ausgedehnten Braunalgen-Blüten
in der Karibik und im zentralen Atlantik.
Und auch die historischen Daten offenbarten,
dass es bislang keine Braunalgen-Blüten gab,
die vergleichbar wären.
Eigentlich sind die Algen auch gar nicht problematisch.
Im Gegenteil: Sie bilden schwimmende Matten
und spielen so eine extrem wichtige Rolle
im Ökosystem der Ozeane.
Denn sie produzieren durch Photosynthese nicht
nur Sauerstoff - wie andere Pflanzen auch
-, sondern bieten auch guten Schutz für Fische,
Schildkröten, Vögel und andere Tiere.
Doch die extreme Ausbreitung der Braunalgen
verwandelt das Paradies zu einer einzigen
Todeszone.
Korallen und Seegräser werden in ihrem ökologischen
Gleichgewicht gestört, denn die toten Algen
sinken auf den Meeresgrund.
Die Braunalgen an der Wasseroberfläche, an
den Küsten und in der Brandung verhindern,
dass sich die Tiere frei bewegen können.
Der Seetang schränkt manche Tiere auch in
ihrer Atmung ein und verhindert die Eiablage
an den Küsten.
Und nicht nur das: Auch der Tourismus spürt
Negativfolgen der Algen-Invasion.
Barbados hat im vergangenen Jahr den nationalen
Notstand ausgerufen.
Der Seetang verrottet am Strand und Schwefelwasserstoffe
entweichen.
So stinkt es wirklich unangenehm nach faulen
Eiern und nicht nur das: Das Gas kann auch
für Benommenheit, Übelkeit und Kopfschmerzen
sorgen.
Klar, dass die Touristen fern bleiben.
Ein großes Problem für Länder, deren Wirtschaft
von dieser Branche abhängig ist.
Soldaten versuchen mit Räumfahrzeugen, gegen
die Algen-Flut anzukämpfen.
Auch die Bevölkerung hilft mit. 2018 hatten
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler den
“Seaweed Summer” an der texanischen Küste
ausgerufen und viele Menschen kamen, um die
stinkenden Berge an Seetang mit Hilfe von
Rechen und Schubkarren zu entfernen.
Weltweit suchen Forschungsteams nach den Ursachen
für diese explosionsartige Ausbreitung der
Algen.
Klar ist, dass das Wachstum der Algen von
der Meerestemperatur, der Sonneneinstrahlung
und dem Nährstoffangebot abhängt.
Höchstwahrscheinlich sind mehrere Faktoren
zu beachten.
Zum einen, dass im Winter Wasserschichten
aus der Tiefe vor der westafrikanischen Küste
nach oben aufsteigen und somit Nährstoffe
an die Oberfläche spülen.
Dies begünstigt das Wachstum der Algen . Aber
auch wir Menschen sind wohl nicht ganz unschuldig
an der Algen-Invasion.
Denn die Nährstoffmenge, die in den Ozean
gelangt, ist durch uns extrem angestiegen.
Zum einen durch den Einsatz von Düngemitteln,
aber auch durch die Abholzung der Wälder.
Große Fläche Amazoniens wurden in Viehweiden
und Felder umgewandelt, die intensiv gedüngt
werden: Dadurch gelangen Phosphate und Nitrate
in den Amazonas, der es weiter ins Meer spült.
Doch nicht nur das: Auch die zunehmende Erwärmung
der Meeresoberfläche sorgt für optimale
Bedingungen für das Algenwachstum.
Weitere Nährstoffe gelangen auch durch Staubstürme
aus der Sahara ins Meer.
Vor allem der Einsatz von Düngemitteln wurde
ab 2010 intensiviert.
Dazu Chuanmin Hu, der an der Studie beteiligt
war: “Ab diesem Zeitpunkt muss sich die
Chemie des Ozeans geändert haben, dass die
Blüten völlig außer Kontrolle gerieten”.
Welche Folgen die Braunalgen langfristig haben
könnten, ist nach Ansicht der Fachleute derzeit
noch nicht wirklich abzusehen.
Doch das US-Forschungsteam prognostiziert,
dass diese explosionsartige Ausbreitung der
Braunalgen auch in den kommenden Jahren weitergehen
wird.
Dazu Chuanmin Hu: "Wenn man sich die Daten
aus den letzten 20 Jahren anschaut, ist es
wahrscheinlich, dass dieser Gürtel in Zukunft
Normalität werden wird."
Schließlich wird die Überdüngung der Meere
weitergehen - ebenso wie die zunehmende Erhöhung
der Meerestemperaturen.
Vor allem die Karibik, aber auch die Staaten
Südamerikas und auch Florida müssen wohl
in Zukunft mit den Braunalgen rechnen.
Doch das könnte auch eine Chance sein.
Die Wissenschaftlerin Hazel Oxenford meint,
dass “mit dem neuen Algen Schwerpunkt zwischen
der brasilianischen und westafrikanischen
Küste langfristig vielleicht sogar ein neues
Ökosystem entstehen” könnte.
Sie nennt es “Sargasso-Süd”.
Eine Folge des Klimawandels.
Und eine weitere ist wahrscheinlich Die: Hitzewelle
2018 durch menschengemachten Klimawandel verursacht?
Anklicken, anschauen und vor allem Clixoom
nature abonnieren.
Da gibt es regelmäßig Videos rund um Umwelt
und Natur.
Nur mit dem Abo verpasst ihr nichts.
Bis dann, bleibt